ก็สวัสดีค่ะวันนี้กำลังเรียมสวัสดีครับ
นักเรียน
เรียนอาหารมาเจอกับพี่อาร์ตี้กับน้อง
เรียมในช่องคอมเพลนสเบอร์ไทยนะครับอ้าวัน
นี้วันนี้เรามาเจอกันวันนี้เรามาเจอกัน
วันวันอะไรครับวันนี้
วันนี้วันอังคารวันนี้วันอังคาร
โอเควันนี้วันอังคารครับวันอังคารที่เท่า
ไหร่ครับวันนี้
วันที่
17  5 วันนี้วันอังคารที่ 17 ครับงาน
เดือนอะไรครับเดือนนี้
เดือนพฤษภาคมเดือนพฤษภาคมนะครับปีพศอะไร
ครับ
ข้อ 2 ต.ค.ลาน 565
อานามก็
2565 แล้วปีคศอะไรครับ
ข้อ
2022 ค่ะใช่ครับข้อ
2022 โอเคอ้าแล้วตอนนี้ตอนนี้อ่าเรามา
เจอกันกี่โมงครับตอนนี้
พอนี้กี่โมงครับ
10:20 น 50 น
20 นาทีเป็นตอนเช้าใช่ไหมครับ
KR  10:20 นน่าวันนี้วันนี้เดี๋ยวพี่มี
เรื่องอ่ามันเล่าให้ฟังนะเป็นเอ่อเรื่อง
หนังอีกแล้วครับวันนี้เรามาเล่าหนังกัน
โอเค
วันนี้เพียบที่เจริญเล่าน่ะเรื่องอะไรค่ะ
หน้าเรานะวันนี้เล่าเรื่องเกี่ยวกับ
มนุษย์ต่างดาว
หน้าเกี่ยวกับมนุษย์ต่างดาวอาอ้าเป็น
สัตว์ที่อยู่นอกโลก
เป็นสัตว์ที่อยู่นอกโลกอันนี้เป็นโรคนะ
ครับอ่าเดี๋ยวพี่วาดโลก
อันนี้เป็นประเทศไทยนั่นแหละนี่คือประเทศ
i  r เป็นโรคงานมีอินเดียพม่าครัวโลกอะ
นี่เป็นโรคนะครับแล้วก็อ้ามีดวงอาทิตย์
นี้เป็นดวงอาทิตย์อยู่ที่นี่แล้วก็มีดาว
ดวงอื่น
ดาวดวงอื่น
มิดสิ่งดิ If สิ่งมีชีวิตที่อยู่ที่ดาว
ดวงอื่น
เราเรียกมนุษย์ใช่คน
อาจจะไม่ใช่คนอาจจะเป็นเอ่อมีรูปร่างเป็น
อย่างอื่นไม่ใช่คนแต่เป็นสิ่งมีชีวิต
เหมือนกันแต่ไม่ได้อยู่ที่โลกขอที่อยู่
ที่โน่ถ้าอยู่ที่โลกอยู่ที่โลกเราเรียก
มนุษย์โลก
อาเฮียตีเป็นมนุษย์มนุษย์โลกน้องเรียน
เป็นมนุษย์ดอกนักเรียนมาเป็นมนุษย์โลกจ้า
อยู่บนโลกนะครับนะแต่มนุษย์ต่างดาวไม่ได้
อยู่บนโลก
หน้านางเรื่องนี้หนังเรื่องนี้มนุษย์ต่าง
ดาวมนุษย์ต่างดาวมาที่โลก
หน้ามาที่โลก
มาทำอะไรคะอ้ามาทำอะไรเดี๋ยวไปดูกันครับ
เดี๋ยวไปดูกันนะมนุษย์ต่างดาวมาทำอะไรที่
หลบอ่านี่ครับเพื่อนกันรู้
เรื่องที่ที่จะเล่านี่น้องเรียนดูมี
อ่ามีสองคนนี้เห็นใส่ชุดแบบนี้ถือมีดถือ
มีดถือปืนอ้าแบบนี้น้องเรียมคลิปว่า
มนุษย์ต่างดาวโทรมาทำไมครับ
อ้าวทำไมไม่มาเป็น
ไม่ได้เป็นเพื่อนจะไม่ถึง
ถือปืน
หาถ้าเป็นเพื่อนต้องถือดอกไม้มาจากนั้น
นี่ไม่ได้ถือดอกไม้ถือปืนถือมีด
น่าจะมาผ้าอ้ามาฆ่าใช่มนุษย์ต่างดาว
ต้องการที่จะไม่อยู่ที่โลกแล้วก็ฆ่าคนฆ่า
คนนะไม่งั้นคนก็ต้องทำไมสู้ต้องสู้ไม่ยอม
ไม่ยอมใช้ครับต้องต่อสู้กันในเรื่องนี้มี
วันนี้ครับพระเอกพระเอกชื่อเคส 5 พระเอก
เป็นทหารหน้า Case เป็นภาคทหารแล้วก็มีอะ
ริต้าศรีริต้าก็เป็นทหารเหมือนกันนะริต้า
เป็นทหารหญิงอ้าร้านอาหารหญิง
นะครับ
โอเคแล้วก็เบี้ยที่
อะไรนะครับ
จะมาสู้อ้ายกันได้ยังไงอ๋อมาสู้กันได้ยัง
ไงใช่ไหมครับโอเคเพราะว่ามนุษย์ต่างดาวมา
ที่โลกเยอะมากนะครับคนก็เลยคิดว่าอ้อถ้า
มนุษย์ต่างดาวมาที่โลกเยอะเนี่ยมนุษย์
ต่างดาวจะฆ่าควรคนก็เลยสู้สู้กันใช้ปืน
ยิงอ่ะเช็คปืนอีกเคสใช้ปืนริต้าใช้มีบวิ
ตาก็มีปืนเหมือนกันมีมีดด้วยแล้วก็ยิงต่อ
สู้กันนะครับ
แล้วก็สู้กันสู้กันนานมากสู้กันนานหลายปี
สู้กันไปประมาณ 5 ปี 5 ปียังไม่ชนะ
คู่กัน 5 ปีแล้วยังไม่ใช้ก็
ยังไม่สนะมีอยู่วันนึงมีอยู่วันหนึ่งอ่า
ริต้าศรีริต้าก็ออกไปสู้กับมนุษย์ต่างดาว
หน้าเหมือนเดิมแต่ริต้าสังเกตว่าเห้ยวัน
นี้มนุษย์ต่างดาวมีเหลือไม่เยอะมีน้อย
มนุษย์ต่างดาวมีน้อย
เพราะมนุษย์ต่างดาวมีน้อยริต้าก็เลยสู้
ชนะชนะมนุษย์ต่างดาวเป็นครั้งแรก
อ้าวเย้
นาริต้าต่อสู้ชนะมนุษย์ต่างดาวนะครับใน
วันนี้
ใช่ค่ะดีมากครับ
หน้าแล้วก็พอวันนี้วันนี้ริต้าสู้ชนะ
หัวหน้าหัวหน้าหัวหน้าของริต้าก็เลยคิด
ว่าอ่ะถ้างั้นพรุ่งนี้พรุ่งนี้พรุ่งนี้
เราเอาทหารอ่ะอาโออินักรบไปเยอะๆเพื่อที่
จะปิดค่ามนุษย์ต่างดาวให้หมด
หน้าเพื่อที่จะไปฆ่ามนุษย์ต่างดาวให้หมด
เลยพรุ่งนี้พรุ่งนี้เอาทหารไปทั้งหมดเลย
อาบ่หน้าหัวหน้าก็เลยบอกว่าทุกๆคนต้องไป
รบทุกๆคนต้องไปรบน้าแล้วนี่ครับคนนี้เป็น
พระเอกพระเอกชื่อเคสจำ Case ได้ไหมครับ
นี่ Case  Case ก็หัวหน้าบอกว่าเคสพรุ่ง
นี้เคสต้องไปรบอาเคเอสคิดว่าอ๋อตัวเองไม่
อยากไปหรอกไม่อยากไปลบให้
หนา
พอเคสเป็นนะคะพี่อ่ะใช่
เก่งเก่งว่าฮะแต่ตอนนี้ตัวเลขยังไม่เก่ง
พระเอกกลัวพระเอกไม่อยากไปลบอ่ะเพราะหัว
หน้าหัวหน้าบอกว่าต้องไปรบ of ไพเราะพระ
เอกวิ่งหนีไปเอกไม่ไปวิ่งหนีฮ่าๆๆงามพระ
เอกไม่อยากไปลบหัวหน้าก็เลยใช้ปืนปืนไฟ
ฟ้าปืนไฟฟ้ายิงยิงพระเอกปืนไฟฟ้าเวลายิง
ก็เป็นไฟช็อตหาพี่เอกก็หลับ
ชายแล้วหัวหน้าก็จับพระเอกส่งไปส่งไปที่
สนามลบ
หน้าได้ครับแล้วพระเอกก็ตอนนี้พระเอกรู้
สึกตัวตื่นขึ้นมาตื่นขึ้นมาเคทตอนที่เคส
ตื่นขึ้นมาเคสก็เห็นว่าอ้าวตอนนี้อยู่ใน
สนามลบแล้วอ่ะนี่ไม่ได้มาแล้วนี่ไม่ได้
แล้วนะตอนที่เคสตื่นขึ้นมาเขาก็อยู่อยู่
ในอยู่ในสนามดอกสนามลบเปียตี้หาสนามรบ
กว่าหน้านี่เคสก็ตื่นขึ้นมาในสนามลบ
เพื่อนๆกำลังลบกันอยู่กำลังฆ่ามนุษย์ต่าง
ดาวอ่า
เคสก็เลยต้องลบนี่ไม่ได้นะครับหน้าแต่ตอน
นี้บางที่เคสตื่นขึ้นมาเคสก็เห็นว่าโห
เมื่อวานมนุษย์ต่างดาวมีนิดหน่อยแต่วัน
นี้วันนี้ที่เขาตื่นขึ้นมามนุษย์ต่างดาว
มีเยอะมีเยอะมาก
ใช่ครับน้ำแล้วทุกคนก็ถูกมนุษย์ต่างดาว
เข้ามาเข้ามาฆ่า Case ก็สู้กับมนุษย์ต่าง
ดาวเหมือนกันอ่ะเคสกอล์ฟอ่ายิงมนุษย์ต่าง
ดาวไปตัวนึงหน้า
หน้าตาเดียวตัวตีเล่าให้ฟังก่อนมนุษย์
ต่างดาวมี 3 แบบนี้มนุษย์ต่างดาวอยู่ 3
แบบมีมนุษย์ต่างดาวตัวที่ตัวที่แปลนเอ่อ
ตัวใหญ่สีน้ำเงิน
น้าตัวใหญ่สีน้ำเงินตัวนี้ชื่ออัลฟา
หน้าแล้วก็มีตัวเล็กสีส้มตัวเล็กสีส้ม
ชื่อ
โดน
โดนหน้าถุงนี้เป็นมนุษย์ต่างดาวที่ต้องไป
ต่อสู้กับมนุษย์มีโดนมี Alpha แล้วก็มี
อีกตัวนึงมี 3 แบบนี้โดนมี Alpha แล้วก็
มีตัวนี้ที่เป็นหัวหน้าใหญ่ที่สุดตัวนี้
ชื่อโอเมก้า
หาชื่อพ่อเมก้าใช่ครับหน้า Omega ตัวนี้
เป็นหัวหน้าใหญ่ที่สุดถ้า Omega ตัวนี้
ตายตัวอื่นๆแต่โดนแล้วจะ Alpha ก็จะตาย
ด้วยเหมือนกัน
แต่วันนี้นี้ก็ไม่ต้องฆ่าไม่ต้องฆ่ารวย
ไม่ต้องฆ่าแต่ฝ้าอ้าค่าโอเมก้าเลยไงคะพี่
ๆต้องไปค่าโอเมก้าเลย 8 ตอนนี้ตอนนี้เคส
ยังไม่รู้ยังไม่รู้ว่าโอเมก้าอยู่ที่ไหน
นะต้องหาโอเมก้าให้เจอ
[เพลง]
KR แล้วตอนนี้ตอนที่
ตอนที่เคสฟื้นขึ้นมาฟื้นขึ้นมาในสนามลบ
ทุกคนก็กำลังลบกันอยู่ใช่ครับ Case ก็
ต้องลบด้วยเสร็จแล้วเคสก็ไปข้าข้า Alpha
ค่า Alpha ได้ตัวนึง
ค่าเอาอยู่ในตัวหนึ่งตอนที่พระเอกยิง
Alpha เลือดเลือดของ Alpha
เลือดของ Alpha ก็กระเด็นกระเด็นมาโดน
มาโดนเคสด้วยตัวของเคสก็เลยกลายเป็นสี
น้ำเงินนะครับหน้าเสร็จแล้วอ่า
Alpha  Alpha ก็ค่าเคส Case ก็ยิงเอาปาก
เอาฝากก็ตาย Case ก็อายเหมือนกันทั้งคู่
อาจ
อ้าวโอเคอ้าพ่อ
เอกตายก็จบเรื่อง
จบ
หน้าแต่อันนี้อันนี้ไม่จบไม่จบเพราะว่า
เอาป้ามีมีความพิเศษอัลฟ่าฆ่าแล้วเอาภาค
ไม่ตาย
Alpha จะกลับไปกลับไปฟื้นขึ้นเอาปืนขึ้น
ใหม่หน้าแล้วตอนนี้ Case ก็โดนเลือดของ
Alpha ทำให้เคสก็ไม่ตาย Case ก็กลับไป
ฟื้นขึ้นใหม่กลับไปฟื้นขึ้นใหม่ในเมื่อ
วาน
เมื่อวาน
นี่เอาเอาฟ้าหรือวางคาย
ๆๆไม่ใช่แวมไพร์อ่าเป็นมนุษย์ต่างดาวนะ
ครับอ่ะ Case ก็กลับมาฝืนกลับมาฟื้นขึ้น
ในสนามลบเหมือนเดิม
แต่ตอนนี้ Case จำได้แล้วจำได้แล้วว่าถ้า
Case เดินไปทางนี้จะเจอมนุษย์ต่างดาวตรง
นี้
เดินไปทางนี้จะเจอเพื่อนจะเจอใครนะครับ
หน้าที่นิเพราะ Case รู้แบบนี้แล้วเคสก็
เลยไม่เดินไปทางที่มีออกปลาแล้วเคสเดินไป
ทางอื่น
แต่น้าเคสเดินไปหาเดินไปหาริต้าครับนี่ไป
คุยกับริต้าไปคุยกับเพื่อนทหารอีกคนนึง
ว่าทำยังไงทำยังไงเราจะไปหา Omega ได้
อ่า
ลิตาสาว
คนนี้รู้เชื่อว่าถ้าเกิดค่าโอเมก้าแล้ว
ถูกต่างดาวทุกๆๆๆกระต่ายใช่สามคนนี้รู้
หน้าสามคนนี้รู้คนนี้เป็นเป็นนัก
วิทยาศาสตร์ใช้ครับโอเคทั้งสามคนนี้รู้
หน้ารู้ว่าต้องฆ่า Omega  Case ก็เลยมา
คุยกันคุยกับริต้าว่าโอเมก้าอยู่ที่ไหน
ตอนนี้ยังไม่รู้ว่าอยู่ที่ไหนริต้าก็บอก
ที่ต้าบอกว่าแต่ตอนที่เคสตายแล้วเคสฟื้น
ขึ้นมาใหม่ตอนที่เคสปายเนี่ยเค้กจะมอง
เห็นจะมองเห็นที่อยู่ของโอเมก้าหน้าเวลา
ที่เคสตาย Case จะต้องจำไม่ได้ว่าเห็น
อะไร
น่า
พอตายแล้วจะเห็นว่าอยู่ที่ไหนนะครับเออที
นี้อ่าพระเอกก็เลยเคสก็เลยออกไปรบใหม่
แล้วแล้วเคสก็โดนยิงอีกโดนมนุษย์ต่างดาว
ฆ่าตายพอพอ Case ตายเคสก็สังเกตอ่ะที่ไหน
ที่ไหนมองเห็นไหมหน้าเคสก็เห็นเห็นที่ที่
1 ครับเห็นที่นี่ครับที่ไหนคะอ่ะเห็นที่
เขื่อน
น่ะนี่เป็นเขื่อนที่ผลิตกระแสไฟฟ้ามีน้ำ
Case สินน้ำเยอะแยะหน้าเห็นคือเขื่อนอัน
นี้เคสก็เลยคิดว่าคิดว่าและนี่แหละ Omega
ต้องอยู่ที่เขื่อนนี่แน่ๆ
5 ดอกเคสก็กลับไปฟื้นกับไปกลับไปฟื้นที่
ไหนครับพี่สนามลบเหมือนเดิม
คำพื้นที่สนามรบตอนนี้จำได้แล้ว
ใช่อ่ะ Case
ตอนนี้เคสฟื้นมาที่สนามลบเคสไปลบมั้ยไม่
ไปเคสไม่เป็นลบแล้วทีนี้เคสไปที่เขื่อน
หน้าเขตก็ตามไปที่เขื่อนครับตามไปที่
เขื่อนเพื่อที่จะเป็นค่าโอเมก้า
เจอเจอไหมตอนนี้ตอนที่เคสตามมาที่เขื่อน
เคสไม่เจอ Omega  Case เจอแตก Alpha
หน้ามี Alpha อยู่เยอะเลยครับที่นี่เพราะ
ว่าถ้าเอาฝ้าเนี่ยตอนที่ Alpha ตาย Alpha
ก็รู้ว่าเคสเนี่ยต้องเห็นเขื่อน Alpha ก็
เลยมารอที่เขื่อนแล้ว Omega ก็หนีไป Omega
ก็ไม่อยู่ที่เขื่อน
หาใช่ครับ
อาธินิอ่ะเพราะเคสเห็นว่าโอ้มีแต่ Alpha
ไม่มีโอเมก้าทำยังไงดี Alpha ก็จะมาจับ
เคส Alpha จะไม่ฆ่าเคสเพราะว่าอะไรเพราะ
ว่าถ้าเอาฝากค่า Case  by  Case  Bag ต่ำ
ไปอีกจะหนีไปได้
อ้าจะกลับไปฟื้นใหม่ของวันเมื่อวานจ้าใช่
แต่ตอนนี้ Alpha ก็เลยก็เลยจับพยายามจับ
เคสแต่ไม่ฆ่าเคสรู้ว่าถ้าเคสถูกจับเคสจับ
แท้
เคสก็เลย
ฆ่าตัวตาย
อ่าใช้ปืนยิงก็
ยิงตัวเองก็เลยตาย
อาข้อตายเพราะตายเคสก็กลับไปฟื้นใหม่ฟื้น
นี่ไงคะครับที่ๆพื้นที่ไหน
พอเคสทำฟืนอยู่สนามรบเคสของฮะรู้แล้ว
เมื่อกี้โดนหลอกโดยมนุษย์ต่างดาวหลอกให้
ไปที่เขื่อนคราวนี้เคสไม่ไปที่เขื่อนแล้ว
หน้าเคสไปที่ไปหาลิตารับไปหาริต้ากลับไป
หาเพื่อนนักวิทยาศาสตร์ไปถามว่า
เราโดนหล่อที่นั่นไม่มีไม่มีโอเมก้า
[เพลง]
แล้วที่นี้ทุกคน
มาหาใหม่มหาไหมว่าโอเมก้าอยู่ที่ไหนนี้นะ
ครับก็เลยคิดว่าเคสต้องตายอีก S ต้องจ่าย
อีกแล้วตอนที่ปลายก็มองหาสถานที่อีกไว้
เห็นสถานที่ที่ไหน
แล้วฆ่าตัวตายอีกไหมคะอ่ะเคสก็ออกไปลบ
ครับให้ลบกับมนุษย์ต่างดาวแล้วก็ถูก
มนุษย์ต่างดาวฆ่าตาย
พ่อตายแล้ว Case ก็กลับไปอ่ะตอนที่ Case
ตายตอนนี้ Case มองเห็นมองเห็นที่ที่ 1
ครับมองเห็นที่มี่น้องเห็นที่นี่น่าเป็น
พิพิธภัณฑ์พิพิธภัณฑ์แห่งหนึ่งตัวที่หาก
ว่านักเรียนนักเรียนน่าจะรู้จักที่
พิพิธภัณฑ์มิ
อ้าวนี่คือพิพิธภัณฑ์ Roof นะครับน้าโอเค
นักเรียนน่าจะรู้จักหมอเทพ
เคสเห็นพิพิธภัณฑ์นี้ตอนนี้เคสตายแล้ว
Case ก็กลับไปฟื้นกลับไปฟื้นใหม่ในสนาม
ลบแต่วันนี้วันนี้ที่เคสฟื้น Case ไปลบ
มั้ยไม่ลบแล้วเคสไม่ -  5  Case ไปที่ไหน
ครับไปที่ไหนคะฮ่าๆๆพี่ไปที่สะพานไอ้ครับ
หน้าพิพิธภัณฑ์รู้ไปไปหา Omega
แล้วคราวนี้ Case เจอ Omega ไหมเจอไหม
คราวนี้เจอเจอเจอนี่ Case เจอ Omega แล้ว
เคสก็ค่าโอเมก้า
นะครับเพราะ Case ค่าโอเมก้านะครับ
rama9 ก็ตายพระองค์ไม่กล้าตายมนุษย์ต่าง
ดาวตัวอื่นๆตัวอื่นและก็ตายเหมือนกันหน้า
ทุกๆตัวก็ตายหมดเพราะว่าโอเมก้าตายแล้ว
โดนก็ตาย Alpha ก็ตายผมไม่กล้าก็ตายเหอะ
หน้าวันนี้เราก็เลยชนะอ้ามนุษย์ก็เลยชนะ
มนุษย์ต่างดาวเย้
เคสก็ไม่ต้องจ่ายอีกเราใช่ครับเราจริงๆ
หรือว่ามนุษย์ต่างดาวโกหกเราชนะจริงๆครับ
เพราะว่าคราวนี้โอเมก้าตายแล้วเนอะ
ทรายเกิดเคสตัวตายเคสจะไปฟื้นที่สนามลบ
อยู่ในฮะอ๋อตอนนี้เคสไม่ฟื้นที่สนามลบ
แล้วครับ
หาจ๊ะตายก็เหอะตายไปเลยอ่อใช่ครับอาจจะ
ตายเลยเพราะว่ามนุษย์ต่างดาวตายไปแล้วอ่ะ
ตอนนี้เคสก็ไม่รู้จะเป็นพื้นที่ไหนจะมี
พลังจะกลับไปอดีตหรือเปล่ากลับไปเมื่อวาน
หรือเปล่าไม่รู้เพราะว่ามนุษย์ต่างดาวตาย
ไปแล้วหืออ้าเรื่องนี้ก็เลยจบนะครับวัน
นี้
โอเคอ่ะหมดเวลาพอดีนะครับหมดเวลาแล้ว
เดี๋ยวรอกลับมาเจอกันใหม่นะครับกลับมาเจอ
กับพี่อาร์ตี้กับมันเจอกับน้องเรียมใหม่
ในช่องคอมเปลี่ยนโซโลไทยคราวหน้าคราวหน้า
เราจะเล่าเรื่องอะไรแล้วเดี๋ยวคอยติดตาม
กันครับ
วันนี้ค่ะเตรียมไปก่อนแล้วค่ะลาไปก่อน
ครับสวัสดีครับนักเรียนสวัสดีครับน้อง
เรียมบ๊ายบาย
สวัสดีค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้มั้ยอ่ะม.ค